I'm joined Now by Texas lieutenant
governor and Dan Patrick as well as New
York congresswoman Claudia tinney thanks
so much for joining the program uh
lieutenant governor I'll start with you
first one thing that annoyed me and I
was there and by the way I'm so proud of
our men and women in the Texas DPS
they're truly the last line of defense
uh for America right now but I I saw
this image and if the producers can put
it up this is not the right way to come
in this country but they were taking
selfies and videos in the welcome
welcome to America sign now they didn't
come here at a Port of Entry they didn't
take the citizenship test or anything
lieutenant governor but this is with the
cell phones that our government provide
them
they're taking selfies
so Lawrence first of all our DPS and our
National Guard and our sheriffs and our
law enforcement across the border they
are doing a tremendous job we're
exhausting them we're exhausting our
resources uh I just passed a budget a
few weeks ago that has four billion
dollars of Texas taxpayer money into it
just for the Border when Trump was
President it was 400 million so we've
had to take it up 10 10 fold and we are
doing a terrific job right now we are
repelling and people are returning to
the other side but they keep coming in
waves so the numbers
have been down a little bit today
because they know Texas means business
we have barbed wire call it concertina
wire whatever you want to call it on the
banks everywhere we keep deploying more
we're filling every Gap we want to force
everyone coming here illegally to come
across those points of entry on the
bridges we don't want them in between
and we're going to all the hot spots our
people are doing a tremendous job but
this President is selling out this
country Lawrence selling out the
American people and all of your guests I
heard on the on the video package there
before said it he doesn't care that
women and children are being sex
trafficked he doesn't care that fentanyl
is coming over the Border he doesn't
care the terrorists and criminals are
coming across the border illegally this
President is a puppet to the left the
reason they got Joe Biden to be their
nominee they needed someone they could
control because he's not even clear
thinking enough to understand what's
going on and mayorkas is a damn liar
yeah he is uh congresswoman uh this is
no longer just a Texas problem get ready
for the mass release I was talking to
the border patrol and they say 60 of the
people that come across across the
border they're just releasing them
they're only Deport 40 percent so
they're coming back to New York and it's
not just the buses that the government
of Texas ascended they're going to be
coming
yeah look Lawrence uh kudos to Texas and
their great leadership of the governor
and the lieutenant governor that are
actually doing something about the
Border we see in New York Governor Kathy
hokel put out a billion dollars in new
taxes to take care of people who are
illegal immigrants and for those people
to be cared for
and that's gonna those are even higher
taxes and we're one of the highest tax
states in the nation but really when you
talk about compassion that question that
was answered look at what's happening in
New York's northern border everyone
forgets we've got this massive northern
border and the rules have been changed
the cartels are controlling the border
and the northern border as well they're
getting illegal immigrants into Canada
they come in there's no Visa requirement
they get to the border the cartels get
them into New York Kathy hokel allows
them to be issued driver's licenses and
they can virtually go anywhere in the
world and anywhere in the country and
they can go wherever they need to go
we're going to provide them with all the
taxpayer funded needs that they have
whether it's food housing Health Care
you name it all over the the you heard
of the illegal the illegals are now
displacing a homeless veterans in New
York City and when you talk about
compassion I want to come back to when
this northern border problem has been
increasing by 800 percent just after I
left my full day meeting with the
northern border and they had four people
die in a swamp right on the in the
Quebec border and they were children two
of them were children and this is not
compassionate and this is human
trafficking fentanyl up 25 killing our
children every single day and this is
this is what you get and and the
Democrats run everything in New York
including the Democratic governor and
they keep encouraging people to come in
and you're gonna you see these Upstate
counties bracing for this congresswoman
you're exactly right they know what
they're doing they just don't care
lieutenant governor congresswoman thanks
so much hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else